being a street dog isn't so bad at all  he's a tram I'm free to be whoever I  want to be walk wherever I want to walk  hey hi are you two twins I'm our husband  pal  ah ha eat whatever I want to keep he's a  champ you know what just remember I got  this the old-fashioned way I stole it  [Music]  snob hell there we go I got my collar  let me just take a little guess here  you're the center of your peoples  universe right you could say that your  family's just perfect  don't please don't well lady that's  basically all over now you're about to  be replaced replace me I don't think so  lady this is Lulu  when the baby moves in the dog moves out  [Music]  help me get this thing off I'm sorry  it's not awkward at all this way totally  safe I'm not gonna do that  keep it crazy you'll know that happen  [Music]  what is this place  but a great big world out there  with no fence around it  [Music]  every day could be an adventure  [Music]  you  [Music]  you